basically you're mean a smells kind of
ruling this red carpet or this whole
Emmys show right we're doing our best
our colleagues are the hosts you may see
80 and eye-popping throughout the show I
love it that's a little tease
what would you be doing throughout the
show you will truly have to watch in
order to find out it's a time secret Oh
what top secret you could give us a
little clue you know just to tease our
audience top secret not like top secret
is that top secret top of the show yep
very good I like it so much so is um are
there any new cast members coming we're
doing all F and L peas I think we have
coming up tell you guys these things I
wouldn't tell you if I did but we don't
even know I honestly don't know no they
don't do yeah well we'll find out when
we show up for work and actually there's
a rumor that you're leaving please tell
us this is not true it's false I will
confirm that but I'm not leaving no I'm
very much returning you're happy if she
was leaving I would be sobbing here so
you know it would be you know people
would know all right in honor of Politan
Michael being the host tonight we need
you to do us a little weekend update'
meaning what have you done on your
weekend Wow
well gotta get your news voices oh you
goes first this weekend I ate salad in
anticipation of this event
and I'm resentful about it and you this
weekend I wrapped a television show that
I've been shooting for the last seven
weeks that's back to you
[Music]